Жодна доросла людина не має права бити дитину.
Завжди більше вірять учителям, дорослим людям, ніж дітям.
Шантаж, погрози, залякування, присоромлення - це чотири наші методи виховання дитини.
Привселюдне приниження, крики чи навіть фізичне насильство.
Уроки схожі на тортури, а поза школою жорстокі розбірки й побиття.
Відеоролики, на яких вчителі й вихователі цькують дітей,
а підлітки б’ють одне одного, регулярно з’являються в соціальних мережах
і щоразу викликають хвилю обурення.
Чим небезпечні приниження й образи, як розпізнати в дитині жертву і чому вчителі дедалі частіше вдаються до приниження учнів
на прикладі типових випадків булінгу пояснює дитячий психолог з багаторічним стажем Олена Ратинська.
Нині, на жаль, ситуація булінгу в нас наростає,
бо все суспільство знаходиться в сильній тривозі
стосовно коронавірусу, стосовно бойових дій і нашого статусу.
І тому ця тривога передається дуже дітям.
У них зараз з’явилося дуже багато невротичних розладів… і  дуже багато агресії.
Шантаж, погрози, залякування, присоромлення -
це чотири наші методи виховання дитини.
Далі такі діти підростають і вони, по-перше, те саме роблять з іншими.
А по-друге, у них немає оцієї гідності, як зі мною можна поводитися.
І коли батьки кажуть, а чому наша дитина жертва? А тому що отак з нею декілька років робили.
І дитина це прийняла за норму ставлення до себе.
Але якщо сюди включити співчуття, що буває не так, як ти хочеш, не завжди так буває,
і також засовувати ногу дитини в чобіт, але при цьому з повагою і добром, то дитина не відчувала би це як насилля.
За словами Олени, діти дошкільного віку та перших класів школи не здатні на булінг через свою емпатичність і бажання триматися в групах.
А от з підлітками ситуація кардинально міняється. Булінг стає звичним явищем вже з 10-річного віку.
І саме тоді батькам потрібно бути особливо пильними до своїх дітей, аби вчасно розпізнати в них жертву.
Якщо дитину булять, то зверніть увагу на такі речі.
Перше - це дитина не хоче ходити в школу. Друге - в неї псується настрій після школи.
Третє - це в неї є якісь супутні фізичні розлади,
психосоматичні захворювання - такі, як панкреатит, біль в животі,
головні сильні болі, простудні захворювання і так далі. В соціальних групах, які пов’язані з класом,
вона або дуже багато сидить у телефоні з агресивним настроєм, або взагалі не спілкується в групах.
Якщо у батьків є довіра з дитиною, тоді достатньо поговорити в спокійній обстановці.
Дуже важливо, щоб батьки не соромили дитину. Не давали ніяких порад дитині в першій цій бесіді.
Задача батьків - це вислухати дитину і поспівчувати їй.
Олена наголошує – булінг це не тільки про стосунки дітей між собою. Приниження від учителів теж доволі поширене явище.
Зараз ми бачимо, як вчитель перейшов на рівень підлітка.
Вона вживає нецензурні вирази, вона ображає дитину.
Таким чином вона думає, що отримує владу над цим підлітком.
Але ми бачимо, що діти, які сидять, посміхаються, бо для них це перемога над вчителем.
І підліток буде дедалі більше конфліктувати з цим вчителем, а можливо, і з іншими, пробувати свою владу.
По-друге, якщо вчитель таки задавить своїм авторитетом і дорослістю дитину,
дитина може пустити цю агресію на себе,
і можуть бути різні самопошкодження, які зараз у нас дуже популярні.
Утім, на думку Олени, у конфлікті учень-учитель часто ініціаторами бувають самі учні.
Я звісно не адвокат вчителів, але
діти по природі в підлітковому віці особливо стають дуже агресивними, тривожними по відношенню до всіх дорослих.
Так, ми бачимо багато роликів про те, як вчителі зриваються на дітей.
Але ми не бачимо того, що було до того.
Дуже мало практики у вчителів щодо того, як вирішувати конфлікти, як не спускатися на рівень дитини в конфліктах,
як формувати й утримувати в собі самоповагу і цю ж самоповагу передавати дитині.
Водночас, за словами Олени, є ситуації, де поведінка вчителів є вкрай неприйнятною і потребує жорсткого покарання.
Саме такий випадок трапився минулого тижня на уроці української мови в одній із шкіл на Львівщині.
Діти зафільмували, як учителька кричить і штовхає хлопчика.
Тут ми взагалі бачимо неприпустиму поведінку дорослого.
Жодна доросла людина не має права бити дитину.
У цьому випадку я би одразу піднімала питання з офіцером,
який є при школі зараз, і виводила би це в якесь офіційне провадження.
Бо поки ми не реагуємо на такі випадки, у нас буде дозволятися така поведінка з дітьми.
Дитячий психолог радить свідкам конфлікту знімати такі випадки на відео,
бо саме воно згодом може пролити світло на причини суперечки.
Відео знімати потрібно, бо це є доказ того, що сталося, бо в нас так склалася ситуація,
що завжди більше вірять учителям, дорослим людям, ніж дітям.
І довести провину практично неможливо. Це по-перше.
По-друге, інколи в цих ситуаціях ми можемо хоча б частково зрозуміти, як воно було насправді.
Хто кого провокував, хто як реагував. Вчителька, коли знаходиться в стані афекту, може не контролювати взагалі свої дії.
А потім вона скаже, що я його трішки штовхнула. Я його тільки назвала дурнем, і все.
А ми бачимо зовсім іншу ситуацію. І повірять, імовірніше, вчителю.
Але Олена застерігає, що саме відеоролики і соцмережі додають олії у вогонь кібербулінгу.
Якщо підліткам важлива увага, важливий епатаж, важлива демонстраційна поведінка,
вони будуть використовувати всі засоби, з якими вони можуть виступити в цей світ.
Зараз дуже популярні соцмережі. Вони будуть знімати відео про свою сміливість,
про свою агресію, про свою девіантну поведінку, яка підтримується тією соціальною групою, де вони спілкуються.
Будуть викладати в соцмерержах, бо це найбільше приверненя уваги до себе.
Олена наголошує, булінг - не тільки проблема в стосунках вчитель-учень чи дітей між собою.
Часто кібербулінгом займаються й батьки у групових чатах класу, принижуючи чи ображаючи
наприклад тих, хто не в змозі чи не хоче здавати гроші на потреби класу.
А часом навіть діти й батьки проявляють цькування по відношенню до вчителів. Особливо це проявилося в умовах пандемії.
Зараз ми бачимо таку ситуацію, що коли діти починають хворіти коронавірусом,
і це стає відомо у школі, коли вони повертаються. Діти починають їх травити за те, що вони є "заразними".
Що треба робити вчителям або вихователям? Треба розмовляти з дітьми про толерантність до цієї проблеми,
про те, що кожен може опинитися в цій ситуації, про співчуття, про обмін ролями.
За прогнозами Олени, ситуація з булінгом має невтішну тенденцію.
Але є деякі прості рекомендації, аби кожен міг долучитися до того, щоб цькування стало менше.
Звертаю увагу на те, що якщо в дитини є емпатія,
якщо дитина може поспівчувати іншим, якщо дитина поважає себе, вона буде поважати інших.
Якщо трапляється така ситуація, що дорослий починає агресивно реагувати на дитину,
обов’язково після цього вибачатися. Діти повинні розуміти, що це не норма.
І тоді ми будемо мати іншу ситуацію, коли буде повага до іншого.